we're highlighting women who are
changing the game and this morning we're
focusing on fashion finding the right
clothes you know can be hard especially
if you're curvy a little bigger than the
other girls i know something about that
christine thompson decided she was going
to do something about it back in 2013
what'd she do she started posting tips
on social media to help women celebrate
their bodies here's a look at christine
in action
tip number one loose clothing that is
meant to hide your body will never make
you look good instead aim to accentuate
your waist and create balance between
your top and bottom half tip number two
a lot of tops come with square hems that
do nothing for your body instead of for
a curved hem that still shows your shape
in your hips while concealing the tummy
area and tip number three embrace
pattern play prints actually trick the
eye and make it about your full look
true true thompson now has one and a
half million followers on tick tock she
also launched her own clothing line
thank you very much it's called ken by
christine back in 2019 and good news
guys you'll soon be able to get it in
nordstrom
on tuesday okay good morning to
christine thompson and bravo to you
thank you so much of us [ __ ] and
complain and moan about clothes but you
decided to do something about it yeah
you started making your own things yeah
yeah so my mother taught me how to sew
when i was younger i didn't really pay
too much attention to it because i was
like i don't really want to sew but as i
got older and started to dress myself i
realized that it was a challenge it was
a challenge to try to find trendy things
that fit me well and so i started to
experiment with clothes take them apart
to see how clothes were made apart and
look at them yeah yeah to see how they
were made and constructed so i could
tweak them to work for my body have you
always been very confident about your
body and ask you because people say
everybody can wear everything and i
actually disagree with that you do not
want to see me in a crop top mini skirt
but there are people who say body
positivity means you can wear anything
do you believe that yeah i think that
whatever makes you feel most confident
is what you should wear so i don't
necessarily think that everything works
for everybody
but there's that doesn't mean that you
need to be excluded from the fashion
trend you can just tweak it to work for
you so crop tops you know that may not
be something that everybody's
comfortable with but you can wear a
flowy skirt with it or something like
that just to show a little bit and just
to get with the trends it's one thing to
to
teach people how to be fashionable yeah
it's another thing to start your own
line yeah that seems scary oh it was so
what was that process like and why did
you decide to do it yeah it was birthed
purely out of frustration i just could
not take it anymore that brands were not
getting the point you know that we just
because we're bigger doesn't mean that
we want we want
shapeless clothes
right right we don't want that we want
trends we want just everything else that
everybody else has
stands for what ken stands for it's an
acronym for my family so obviously ken
means family but it's the first letters
of the names of the most important women
in my life so it's christine mean the k
um i for iris who's my mom and n for
nicole so let's talk about nordstrom
because i like what nate said to start
your own fashion line but then you get
an email from nordstrom's did you think
am i being punked is this what did they
say to you i mean i saw that at
nordstrom.com so i knew it was real but
i still
it was just a story
of course he checks for yeah of course i
didn't just take it at face value
because i could not believe that they
were reaching out to me um but their
buyers reached out to me and said we're
interested in carrying your line we
really want to ramp up our plus business
and so
it was just
i didn't know how we were going to do it
we were still so young we're still very
young as a company
but i could not pass up this opportunity
i said well if it's coming to me then
that means that it's a major department
store and you're engaged to be married i
am do you have a dress
that's a big that's a big fashion
question yeah i don't know who's making
it
no oh okay all right
there's many things that i can take on
that is not one of them you're looking
for a designer for your i am i am and
i'm finding it to be pretty challenging
why why there aren't a lot of bridal
salons that are truly inclusive in that
you can go in as a bigger woman and
actually try on the dress there are a
lot of them where you can try it on in
smaller size yeah but you don't know how
it looks until probably a month before
your wedding day when it's too late to
really make any alterations you know how
to sew it sounds like the beginning of a
new product line oh oh oh oh
wedding downs by ken coming in exactly
do you know christian siriano he makes
beautiful things i mean i'm a huge fan
of yeah
yeah i have met him in person but i
don't know him personally but
that would be amazing
i did not have a wedding dress
well you look great now and i know
you're going to be spectacular on your
wedding congratulations congratulations
bravo